edwards
gets into the paint anthony edwards it
is his night he's up to 32.
that's a nice lefty finish right there
back to edwards
their their job is to protect the rim
edwards
ants can kill and edwards is trying to
take a bite out of memphis here tonight
to his left here and as he completes his
plan valentine's
looks at his right bicep
if i was built like anthony
sizin up clark steps back make it seven
in the game for ant anthony edwards had
22 the last time to the first meeting
he's got 37 here tonight
dilo hasn't knocked away edwards though
comes up with it
and edwards has got 39. spectacular
anthony edwards is going to make 203s
over 203s
every year from this point forward i
think john marantz
just killing people in the painted area
marantz steps back unbelievable john
morant
that's his first make from outside the
paint tonight
morant creates some space
and rattles it home morant's got 37 in
the game
rubio gets it into edwards and steps
back for three and anthony edwards are
you kidding
his eighth three of the game natural to
him
definitely
with 22 points the game after
he set his career high with 22 anthony
edwards ties his career